yeah it's like there's like a beak eat
like a yurt you have a beehive on your I
like it it's not a beehive it's just
regular her well you know what babe what
you did the other night to me I should
get I'm gonna get revenge on you baby
what happened wasn't even intentional
you scared himself no no no no
so last night okay it's like 2:00 3:00
in the morning you know Papa likes to go
outside and relax you know I was a born
relaxer ever since I was a baby I just
enjoyed just chillin you know what I
mean
I like naps I like sleepy time at night
I also like closing my eyes and
daydreaming
you know I like it all I don't like my
body isn't you know physical and I have
to do physical things I don't enjoy it
as much you know like peloton but I was
trying to get a peloton sponsorship
please say you like something I do die
not peloton every night baby do okay you
every night but you know the other night
at Papa's doing relaxations you know
yeah yeah yeah the way you know he was
made to do you know so I'm laying
outside I'm smoking my cigarette and you
know during Papa's relaxations at 2:00
3:00 in the morning on the back yard I
like to listen to mute music sad core
mmm some sad core music you know I mean
I like to get deep depressed you know I
mean and and have a cigarette
and just ponder about you know our life
predicaments and whatnot I have a
question does them when you like a song
that makes you sad is it the melody the
lyrics or the combination of both I
generally don't know what any song is
about I realized that yeah so yeah
surely good I've never liked listen to
song go I relate to that song you know
through lyrically because and even if I
do understand it you know I mean when
they say stuff like let me be go or
whatever I don't understand it
not that there was a song like that but
so album I'm outside right relaxing just
listen to me let me be go and listen to
my music and um it's pitch black out
cigarettes and I don't think anybody is
outside because no one is supposed to be
outside it's my time to roll
mm-hmm and some smoking this and that
and all of a sudden I see the silhouette
of a ghost
what yes but this ghost happened to be
holding an animal right so I go right I
go and then my cigarette flies like the
matron all I could see in the dark
honestly it was like fireworks went off
in his face for it it just flicks every
single party like [ __ ] fourth of July
I look like Ghost Rider for a second you
know and I look I was so scared and it
looked at Cole and kalila was there with
the dog right it's like hey [ __ ] you
know how about how about a little hand
like I'm here you know I didn't know
that he had his ear pods on so I went
out and I had to pee Remy because we
needed to pee so I Remy's old so I
carried him and I put him in the grass
and I waved at him I was like hey babe I
didn't know he had hair pods on so I
just thought he knew I was there Yeah
right
and then so but then it's like you know
I was angry because I don't like to get
surprised
yeah it's scared in that way also these
to know that I'm living with is I'm the
worst person to see a whole horror movie
with we saw what the visit the other day
you've seen like three times
it doesn't matter every time do that
class space scene is terrible why people
always chasing you underneath the
[ __ ] house is so [ __ ] scary if it
was a black person you wouldn't be that
scared like oh hello sir hello if it was
an Asian you think oh they're doing you
know you know what sort of you are round
Oh
white people really are scary yeah they
are very one of the most scariest people
mm-hmm when they're on look at George
doubting us yeah you see how how you
looked up yeah they always they always
give your workers that's uh that's a
you know what babe asian is like we had
we had there's folklore in our old town
and there was this lady named one name
that's her name
one Ning yeah when they would scare all
of us like neighborhood tuning tuning
morning is fine was just an old lady
that everyone sort of saw but she didn't
speak a lot I don't think she had
dementia but she was like a hunchback
like she was honestly like in her late
90s mmm but she would mind her own
business but our parents to like so that
we wouldn't stray too far from home we
would say hey like careful you know cuz
then one name would come get you and
then one hang wondering apparently at
night she morphs into a very mobile old
lady and she goes through your windows
so if you're misbehaving she'll come get
you and also if you're pregnant she'll
steal your baby right jewels is that how
it goes yeah Wow one thing is [ __ ]
wicked I mean it's not one it's one Ning
yeah one thing to name to name three
Dean alright alright so yeah I I can't
no I can't get her back because she has
a heart condition it's true right so she
can [ __ ] freak me out all [ __ ]
night long but she has a heart condition
so public so that I let it go alright
because you know why I'm a good dude
good heart yeah I also realize why you
and I and Jules could never watch horror
films together why it's because we're
products of extreme physical trauma
so like our body reacts to perceived
threats in a different way we're like
George you know it's probably very calm
and collective and objective when he
sees a horror film for us it's like our
fighter flight is very jumpy so it
switches on real quick yeah George is
member like oh that situation was very
so then I let it go but then kalila does
something last night
Manjiri me oh you don't know you don't
remember remember I think she forgot so
she goes hold on one second last week he
was he was so okay so last week Bobby's
sorry oh [ __ ] it I've never heard her